ah
[Música]
a
en ecuador a de 49 por ciento de los
jóvenes entre 15 y 30 años están
preocupados ansiosos o deprimidos a
causa de la pandemia así lo reveló un
estudio las naciones unidas realizado en
el país andino acerca el pesimismo
juvenil luego de cinco meses de
aislamiento social los indicadores
internacionales coinciden con el informe
de desempleo del instituto nacional de
estadística ocho de cada diez personas
se están desempleadas en el mercado
informal significa un millón de personas
que perdieron su empleo en cinco meses
de emergencia sanitaria el cambio de la
clase presencial es algo virtual también
preocuparon jóvenes en un país donde
todavía existen brechas digitales en el
acceso al internet oa dispositivos
electrónicos el bienestar psicológico y
la salud mental de los pobres está
golpeado según las naciones unidas para
quienes no es lo mismo saludar con el
codo en una cultura acostumbrada al
abrazo a los besos o el saludo con las
manos paralelamente la credibilidad del
presidente de lenin moreno y la
evaluación de su gestión cayó al 8% de
77 por ciento con que comenzó su gestión
según la encuestadora cedatos en calor a
siete meses de las elecciones
presidenciales el 95 por ciento los
ecuatorianos
en sus políticos
[Música]
la situación laboral de los jóvenes en
venezuela que ya venía afectada antes de
la pandemia ha empeorado después de
decretada la cuarentena por el gobierno
nacional a mediados de marzo los últimos
tres años los jóvenes venezolanos han
emigrado a otros países debido a la
falta de empleo y los bajos salarios la
encuesta de condiciones de vida encovi
en su última publicación señala que
antes de la llegada del cobi 19 al país
el 44% de los mayores de 15 años estaba
desempleado la plataforma juvenil
gritemos con brío ha hecho una encuesta
durante pandemia y el resultado señala
que el 68% de los jóvenes entre 15 y 35
años no tienen empleo en estos momentos
la curva de desempleo según esta misma
plataforma continuará creciendo debido
al confinamiento a las pocas políticas
de apoyo de la empresa privada y a la
caída del poder adquisitivo en los
venezolanos
[Música]
en nicaragua los jóvenes representan el
76% de la población según datos
oficiales y pese a ser la mayoría de sus
condiciones no son las ideales este
grupo poblacional fue uno de los más
afectados tras la represión a las
protestas en 2018 y la posterior crisis
económica y política en nicaragua ahora
los jóvenes enfrentan un nuevo desafío
la pandemia del coronavirus según la
fundación nicaragüense para el
desarrollo económico y social funides la
tasa de desempleo abierto podría cerrar
este 2020 entre 72 y 93 por ciento como
consecuencia de coronavirus los jóvenes
laboralmente activos trabajan en áreas
como servicio ventas y atención al
cliente que son los sectores más
afectados por la crisis económica post
kobe 19 según estimaciones
independientes al cierre de este año
podría haber unas 230 mil personas en el
desempleo y la gran mayoría de éstas
podrían ser jóvenes aunque el gobierno
se muestra más optimista y asegura que
tan sólo este año se han creado 7.000
nuevos emprendimientos y 34 mil nuevos
puestos laborales
[Música]